les salles obscures retrouve la lumière
à l'entrée on peut lire welcome back ou
content de vous revoir
un message que les cinéphiles de big
apple n'ont pas attendu de lire pour se
ruer dans les salles
je me sens excitée et heureuse
je me sens bien en fait je suis
infirmier je viens de quitter mon
travail
vous avez revenir un an plus tard je
m'occupe du coc vidé de tout ça et je
suis content de revenir au cinéma le
crépitement et l'odeur du pop corn
rien de tel pour oublier le coc vide le
temps d'une séance 1 depuis le 17 mars
2020 toutes les salles de la capitale
américaine ont été contraintes de fermer
par un décret du maire bill de blasio et
c'est ce lundi que le gouverneur de
l'état andrew cuomo a annoncé la bonne
nouvelle avec bien évidemment des
mesures à respecter
réservation de sa place en ligne jauge à
25% de la capacité soit 50 personnes par
salle maximum port du masque obligatoire
distanciation social nettoyage des
salles entre chaque séance et
ventilation améliorée pour certaines
malgré ces contraintes c'est une
véritable bouffée d'oxygène pour les new
yorkais
j'ai entendu dire que les salles ouvrait
pour la première fois et je suis
tellement là c'est de m'asseoir sur mon
canapé et de regarder des films en
streaming
alors je suis sorti de la maison et
bizarrement j'ai été attiré par un film
qui traite du désespoir et de l'
isolement
mais pourquoi pas après tout c'est le
bémol peut des blockbusters sont pour
l'instant à la fiche
les studios hollywoodiens ayant décalé
la majorité des films à gros budget
ajoutez à cela les mesures de
restriction qui ont contraint certaines
salles à rester fermés néanmoins comme
ce directeur certains veulent rester
positif
une fois que le film commencera les
lumières vont s'éteindre ce sera comme
dans toutes les autres grandes
expériences théâtrales que vous avez
vécu mais avant et après ce sera un peu
différent
toutes les places sont réservées ce qui
signifie qu'il n'ya pas de files
d'attentes pour les meilleures places
vous choisissez vos places en ligne et
puis une autre différence c'est qu'il
n'y aura pas de gens autour de vous
à boire et à manger sans masquer des
points encourageants mais reste à savoir
si ces réouvertures en capacité réduite
seront économiquement viable pour ces
salles qui voit en cette réouverture
une première étape cruciale dans la
relance de leur activité